Kevin Nick friedel ESPN
hi
how would you sum up your time in
Brooklyn
[Applause]
it was uh it was a
it was a lot of ups and downs but I love
the grind so and everybody in Brooklyn
loved the grind too so I built the
family over there is they gonna always
be a part of my journey uh so we didn't
accomplish what we wanted to accomplish
as far as winning the championship just
like I told him but I enjoy the grind
and everybody there we tried our hardest
every day regardless of what was going
on in the media what was going on with
our teammates everybody who's in that
gym we grind it so I love those guys I
get emotional talk about them because
that was a special four years of my
career coming off of Achilles and they
helped me through a lot so I don't have
anything
[Applause]
um
so yeah it was terrible how some stuff
went down but at the end of the day I
love to grind and we all love to grind
there in Brooklyn and I wish them the
best going forward they got a bright
future
as you look back on that time I know how
much you guys wanted to win a title why
don't you think it worked there for you
guys together
we just didn't get on the court enough I
think when you've seen James Kyrie and
myself it was it was amazing basketball
for 17 games though
but you need in order for you to win a
championship and be a great team you
just need more time on the floor we
could it's another story about why we
didn't get on the floor together but we
just didn't get enough time on the floor
and um those are Hall of Fame players
that I learned a lot from every day and
I'm wishing them the best as well uh it
just didn't work out
hey James over here this is Dave King
with SB Nation welcome to the valley
we're happy to have you here
foreign
I have a very short two-part question
first what is it about Devin Booker that
makes all-time greats like Chris Paul
and now you want to play with him and
come to the valley and get traded to the
size
and my second part is when are you going
to take the court
[Applause]
I asked for the second part first I
don't know but hopefully soon you know
hopefully you can feel my enthusiasm to
get ready to get out there and play but
I'm a I'm gonna follow the training
staff and and go on the schedule they
got me on so hopefully hopefully soon
after break
um but as far as Devon is just he has a
pure game he can score from every area
of the floor with efficiency he's
athletic but he don't really show it a
lot but he can like last last game he
had two dunks it surprised me out of
nowhere even though I know he has that
in his tool bag but he's just such a
quiet efficient scorer and he goes about
his business on and off the court and
just a mature Manner and um I just
wanted to be a part of be a part of it I
wanted to be a part of this journey and
see you know how good he can get from
here and you know he's just one of those
players that uh I really admire and
people are going to be doing classes on
him once he's done playing like you can
learn so much from watching his game
Kevin Shane Young with sports welcome to
the valley
um do you think your defense still gets
under discussed uh being in you know
almost two decades in the NBA and people
still talk about your offense do you
feel like uh that gets under discussed
and how much do you think you're gonna
be able to contribute on that end for
money and the staff uh yeah I mean yeah
I understand why I mean I can score the
basketball people who like scoring and
defense is not the Glamorous thing in
the game so yeah I understand why it may
not be discussed as much but my coaches
and my teammates uh trust in me in that
on that side of the floor and I'm
looking forward to adding that to this
team I see they do a lot of switching on
some stuff and they fight over a lot of
screens the stuff that I like to do
protect the rim and you know I think I
add value to a team with my defense and
like I said earlier I think my defense
always feeds into my offense so when I'm
locked in on that end I could be better
on the other side
foreign
to your left
Chris Mannix
with what's Illustrated Kevin you were
18 and two the Nets were before your
injury
I want to know what was your reaction to
Kyrie's trade request is there any part
of you disappointed that you couldn't
have finished what you started yeah I
was upset that we couldn't finish I
thought we would have some good momentum
we were
finally building the culture that we
always wanted I felt like every game we
were building our chemistry but I didn't
know what was going on with Kyrie and
his situation with the organization so I
didn't really focus on that I only
focused on what we were doing on the
court and it was a blow to our team it
just took away our identity he was a
huge huge part to what we do his game
he's the Hall of Fame player a great
great player that can do everything on
the floor and we relied on that so
without him we didn't have a clear
identity so that was tough for me to
stomach and I love playing with those
guys throughout the year I felt like we
had dudes with that were stepping up and
doing stuff that they didn't do on their
previous team so I enjoyed everything
about it and it was tough to not finish
the season but
um you know I just tried to move forward
as quickly as I can and try to figure
something out for myself but also still
focus on trying to rehab and get back so
it all happened so fast but I'm glad it
worked out this way
all right we'll do one final question
Kevin right here calling Harmon ABC 15
Sports you came into the league at the
tail end of the seven seconds or less
era and
you know all that Talent was homegrown
on that team now I look at the backdrop
and two of the four up there future Hall
of Famers that chose to want to come to
Phoenix I'm curious how the maybe the
evolution and the the perspective among
Superstar players in the league about
playing in Phoenix has evolved in in
your time in the league
oh it's definitely involved I mean I I
felt like once I got into the league I
came in at 07 Phoenix was always one of
the top teams in the league
um it only been a few years actually
um where they you know they weren't one
of the top teams so um they always had a
solid team somebody always respected and
when you came in here this was a this
was a battle you know you know the crowd
was going to be in tour from the
um from the tip and I think one of the
one of the best teams that you know
since I've been in League was that team
that didn't make the playoffs that were
like 45 and 37 I think with the twins
and PJ Tucker I think that was one of
the teams that really sold me on like
all right this is a this is a this is a
destination to come play this is a place
that you know they really get behind
their team so
um and also just the style of play that
team had I feel like that's always
evolved in this the fast pace here in
Phoenix so
um that Drew me here you you know you
always keep an eye out on organizations
and teams throughout the league
throughout your career and this is one
of the teams always and one of the
Cities always respected and you know I'm
glad I was a disabled to come full
circle and I'm here now
thank you for helping us
ing us Kevin Durant to the valley we
asked that all fans make their way to
the exit we hope to see you back here
tonight when the Suns take on the Los
Angeles Clippers at 8 pm here at